Segues are used to transition from
one view controller to another in
the story board.
There are many types, for now we're
going to use the show segue to display
a new view controller and its view on
top of the existing view controller.
We've got a couple more steps
until Pitch Perfect is ready for
the app store.
We have to set up the playback view,
and for
that I'm going to show you an amazing
new tool called stack views,
that will make your life with other
layout constraints a lot easier.
In addition, we have to actually record
the audio in the first view controller,
and pass that along to the second one.
Luckily, in iOS, that's but
a few lines of code to use with
the segue you just created.
It may seem like a lot of steps, but so
far, you've created the foundation
of your first iOS app.
You built the beginning of two screens,
and you're ready to
add in audio with the help of another
iOS framework called AV Foundation.
Take a breather, and when you're ready
I'll be there in the next section.